Transcriber: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Mehmet Şeker
Saffet Emre Tonguç
Modern Evliya Çelebi
Yüz otuz civarında ülkeye gitmiş, yüzlerce
şehir görmüş bir seyahat yazarı
ve profesyonel bir rehber olarak ben size
en sevdiğim şehri anlatacağım.
Hatta bu şehirle ilgili
bir sloganım da var:
‘’İstanbul’da yaşamayın,
İstanbul'u yaşayın.’’ diye.
Fakat bunun için öncelikle
bir psikiyatristin koltuğuna oturup
çocukluğuma, geçmişe geri
dönmem gerekiyor.
Benim çocukluğum, bana göre İstanbul’un
en güzel köyünde geçti, yani Kandilli’de;
iki bin kişinin yaşadığı,
iki sarayın bahçeleri arasına
bir vadiye sıkışmış bir köyde.
Ve benim çocukluğumda hâlâ
mahalleli kültürü vardı.
İnsanlar birbirlerini tanırlardı ve
şimdiki gibi servis minibüsleriyle
okula gidilmezdi.
Bir pasom vardı vapura binerdim,
bu Şirket-i Hayriye'nin vapurlarına
ve onunla kıtalar arası yolculuk yaptığımı
bilmeksizin Beşiktaş’a giderdim.
Oradan da 1950 model Cadillac’lara,
aynı zamanda Chevrolet’lere biner
ve Nişantaşı’ndaki okuluma giderdim.
Bugün okulumun yerinde
alışveriş merkezi var.
Bu İstanbul’u sevmeme engel mi?
Asla değil.
Hâlâ İstanbul’un her şeye rağmen Dünya'nın
en güzel şehri olduğuna inanıyorum.
Ve bu çerçevede isterseniz gelin
İstanbul’da birazcık dolaşalım diyorum.
Şimdi İstanbul’u dolaşmak için
ne yapmak lazım?
Tarihi Yarımada'ya gitmek lazım,
yani Suriçi denilen bölgeye.
Biliyorsunuz İstanbul yedi tepe
üzerine kurulmuş.
Neden?
Çünkü Roma yedi tepe üzerine kurulmuş.
O yüzden de Konstantin buraya
geldiğinde yedi tepe üzerine kurulu
yeni bir şehir istemiş.
Bu yüzden şehrin diğer bir adı da
Yeni Roma olarak geçiyor.
Ve ne yapmış?
Yedi tepeyi birbirinden güzel
eserlerle taçlandırmış.
Sakın yedi tepe neresidir diye sorarlarsa
Çamlıca, Güzeltepe, Fikirtepe,
Gayrettepe falan demeyin.
Hepsi bunların tarihi
yarımadada yer alıyor.
Ve Osmanlılar ne yapmış?
Yedi tepeye birbirinden
güzel camiler yapmış.
İsterseniz bunları bir
sayarak başlayalım işe.
Birinci tepede Sultan Ahmet Cami var.
Altı minaresiyle çok görkemli
ve tam karşısında da bana göre dünya
mimarlık tarihinin en olağanüstü
eserlerinden bir tanesi olan Ayasofya,
yani Kutsal Bilgelik Kilisesi bulunuyor ki
şu anda bir müze olarak kullanılıyor
ve içine girdiğinizde, iki dinin bir arada
kardeşlik içinde görebileceğiniz
dünyadaki tek mekân olarak geçiyor.
Oradan ikinci tepeye geçiyoruz.
Bizi selamlayan, karşımıza çıkan,
Nuruosmaniye Cami.
Tam Kapalı Çarşı'nın girişinde.
III. Osman yaptırdığı için ne demiş?
"Osman'ın Işığı" demiş ve gerçekten
ışıklar içerisinde bir cami.
Ama üçüncü tepeye gittiğinizde, bana göre
şehrin en muhteşem cami bulunuyor.
Koca Sinan’ın yaptığı; Süleymaniye.
Kanuni’nin tahta çıkışının
otuzuncu yıl dönümünde yapmış bunu
ve dört tane minareyle
süslemiş bu camiyi.
Neden dört tane minare?
Çünkü Kanuni, Osmanlı’nın İstanbul’u
fethinden sonra başa geçen dördüncü sultan
ve aynı zamanda on tane de birbirinden
güzel şerefe, yani balkon yapmış.
Bu da Kanuni’nin, Osmanlı’nın kuruluşundan
itibaren onuncu sultan
olduğunu gösteriyor.
İsterseniz dördüncü tepeye
doğru yola çıkalım
ve karşımıza Fatih Cami’nin
çıktığını göreceğiz.
Fatih Camii aslında
baktığınızda Osmanlı’nın
dört yüz yıl yaşadığı saraydan çok uzakta.
Peki neden orayı seçmiş?
Aslında bir sebebi var.
Çünkü Kanuni üçüncü tepeye yapmış,
fakat dördüncü tepeye Fatih yapmış.
Çünkü orada Konstantin’in
mezarı bulunuyormuş.
Yani şehrimizi kuran kişinin mezarı.
Ve Havarium Kilisesi’nin,
On İki Havariler Kilisesi’nin içindeymiş.
Dolayısıyla kendisini çok önemli bir
Roma İmparatoru’yla özdeşleştirdiği için
dördüncü tepeyi tercih etmiş Fatih.
Ve çok enteresan bir şey daha söyleyeyim,
türbesi de hemen Konstantin’in Türbesi’nin
olduğu yere yapılmış.
Beşinci tepeye geldiğimizde ise muhteşem
bir başka cami ile karşılaşıyoruz.
Çarşamba’da Yavuz Sultan Selim Cami.
Fatih’in devamında bulunuyor
Yavuz Sultan Selim Cami
ve Kanuni’nin babası için yapılmış.
Haliç’e, o muhteşem manzaraya
bakan, olağanüstü bir cami.
İsterseniz altıncı tepeye gidelim.
Altıncı tepede ise Mihrimah Sultan
Cami’ni göreceksiniz.
Şimdi hep bir hikâye vardır,
Mihrimah'a âşıktı Koca Sinan,
onun için birbirinden güzel
iki tane cami yaptı.
Bir tanesi Üsküdar’daydı,
bir tanesi ise Edirnekapı'daydı.
Yani altıncı tepedeydi.
Edirnekapı’da güneş batarken,
Üsküdar’da ise ay çıkardı.
Bu gerçek mi?
Aslında gerçek olup olmadığı bilinmiyor.
Peki nedeni ne?
1972 de Arthur Stratton isimli bir İngiliz
bir kitap yazıyor, Mimar Sinan kitabi.
Aynı dizi taktiği, kitabın çok
satması için ne yapacak?
Kan, kin, nefret, aşk,
entrika katacak işin içine.
O yüzden de böyle bir hikâye uydurmuş
ve Koca Sinan’ın Mihrimah’a
âşık olduğunu söylemiş.
Çünkü Mihrimah'ı biliyorsunuz
güneş ve ay demek.
O yüzden de Arthur Stratton güneşli
aylı bir aşk hikâyesi yapmış.
Yedinci tepeye geldiğimizde çoğu zaman
insanlar nerede olduğunu bilmezler.
Oysa bana göre İstanbul’un en çok tarihi
eser olan semtlerinden biridir.
Ama biz maalesef oradaki
hastaneyi biliriz; Cerrahpaşa.
İstanbul’un yedinci tepesidir ve gene
Mimar Sinan’ın bir eseri karşımıza çıkar.
Bu sefer neyi görürüz?
Haseki Hürrem Cami’ni görürüz.
Bunlar İstanbul’un birbirinden
güzel yedi tepesi.
Ama sadece güzellikler burada değil,
İstanbul’un tamamına dağılmış bir şekilde.
Çok şanslı olduğumuzu düşünüyorum.
Çünkü İstanbul iki kıta üzerine kurulmuş,
üç imparatorluğa yani Roma’ya, Bizans’a
ve Osmanlı’ya ev sahipliği yapmış,
olağanüstü bir şehir.
Aynı zamanda içinden deniz geçen
tek şehir olarak geçiyor.
İsterseniz yukarıdan, tepelerden aşağıya
inelim ve Mısır Çarşısı civarına gelelim.
Mısır Çarşısı biliyorsunuz,
İpek Yolu'nun son durağı.
Oraya gelen baharatlar, Mısır Çarşısı’ndan
Avrupa’nın değişik limanlarına götürülmüş.
Fakat hemen yakınında, bana göre
mücevher gibi bir cami var.
Zaten Newsweek dergisi de,
Avrupa’nın Elli Mücevher'inden
bir tanesi olarak belirtti bu yeri:
Rüstem Paşa Cami.
Yani Mihrimah’nın kocası için
yapılan Rüstem Paşa Cami
ve olağanüstü İznik çinilerini
göreceğiniz bir Mimar Sinan eseri,
Rüstem Paşa Cami.
Fakat Rüstem Paşa Cami’nde
bu çinilerin bir kısmı çalınmış.
Bununla ilgili bir anımı
anlatmak istiyorum.
Ağırlıklı olarak Amerikalılarla
tur yapıyorum.
Bir gün bir aile ile şehri dolaşıyoruz
ve aile dedi ki,
''Biz Rüstem Paşa
Cami’ne gitmek istiyoruz.''
Çok sevindim, dedim ki ne kadar sofistike
insanlar, ne kadar bilgililer,
Rüstem Paşa’nın farkındalar, böyle güzel
bir cami olduğunu da biliyor.
Çünkü herkes biliyorsunuz Sultan Ahmet
Cami’ne gider, Süleymaniye’ye gider.
Bunlar dedim küçük de olsa
çok güzel mücevher gibi
bir camiyi görmeye gidecekler.
Biz gittik.
Ben heyecanlı bir şekilde sordum
''Nereden biliyordunuz bu caminin
bu kadar özel olduğunu? ''
Adam şöyle bana bir baktı.
‘’Amerika’da’’ dedi ‘’çok ünlü bir
müzayede salonu var,
burada çalınan çinileri sattılar,
çiniler de bizim evde duruyor,
nerede olduğunu merak ettiğimiz
için gelip baktık’’ dedi.
Böyle içime böyle bir acı sindi.
Ama keşke çaldırmasaydık ve hâlâ aynı
yerde dursaydı o güzelim çiniler.
Onun tam karşısında hep önünden
geçtiğimiz bir başka cami var:
Ahi Çelebi Cami.
Ve caminin çok ilginç bir özelliği var.
Evliya Çelebi’yi biliyorsunuz,
orada bir gün uykuya dalıyor
ve rüyasında ne diyor biliyor
musunuz Evliya Çelebi?
‘’Şefaat ya Resulallah’’ diyeceğine
‘’Seyahat ya Resulallah’’ diyor.
Ve ondan sonra da bütün dünyayı
gezmeye başlıyor.
İsterseniz Galata Köprüsü’nden
karşıya doğru geçelim.
Galata Köprüsü aslında
iki kıtayı değil
ama eski ile yeni şehri
birbirine bağlıyor.
Ve çok ilginç de bir hikâyesi var.
Kırım Savaşı esnasında İngiliz askerler
bu köprüden geçiyorlar.
Köprüyü çok beğeniyorlar
ve ondan ilham alıyorlar
ve tarihi yarımadada oynadıkları oyuna da
köprüden dolayı "bridge"
yani "köprü" adını veriyorlar.
Ve gerçekten de Galata Köprüsü sayesinde
eski ile yeni şehir buluşuyorlar.
Çünkü Bizanslılar ve Osmanlılar,
yüzyıllarca hep tarihi yarımadada,
Suriçinde yaşıyorlar.
Karşıya baktıkları için
Bizanslılar ne diyor?
"Karşı" yani "Pera" diyorlar ve köprü
yapıldıktan sonra Pera’ya taşınıyorlar.
Özellikle de Levantenler,
yani Avrupalı gayrimüslimler,
Pera’da oturmayı tercih ediyorlar.
Ve birbirinden güzel binalar yapılıyor.
Bana göre İstanbul’un en sıradan
olma sebeplerinden biri
birbirinden güzel mimariye sahip olması.
Baktığınızda Roma’yı Bizans’ı Osmanlı’yı,
ama Avrupa’nın da Barok'undan tutun
Art Nouveau'suna kadar bütün mimari
üsluplarını görebiliyorsunuz.
Bir Pera Palas Oteli var,
dünyalar güzeli bir otel
ve İkinci Dünya Savaşı’nda
baktığınızda bu Pera Palas Oteli,
adeta bütün casusların
cirit attığı bir yer olmuş.
Mata Hari de o casuslardan bir tanesi.
Ama bana göre en ilginç hikâye
sahibi ile ilgili.
Sahibi Misbah Muhayyeş,
Beyrut’lu ve Atatürk’e de
Kurtuluş Savaşı esnasında
çok yardımcı olan isimlerden biri.
Dolayısıyla Misbah Muhayyeş
otelde güzel zaman geçiriyor.
Ama çok asosyal bir adam
ve hiç kimselerle konuşmuyor.
Bir tane kedisi var on dokuz kiloluk
ve insanlar onunla sohbet edebilmek için
kediye iyi davranmak zorunda kalıyorlar.
Bir gün kedi ölüyor.
Adam başını duvarlara
vura vura intihar ediyor.
Demek ki para her zaman
saadet getirmiyor.
Ve hemen aşağı inelim
isterseniz Pera’dan.
Tophane’de karşımıza olağanüstü
güzel bir cami çıkacak.
Caminin adı Kılıç Ali Paşa Cami.
Gene bir Mimar Sinan eseri.
Mimar Sinan yapmış bu muhteşem camiyi.
Fakat batılı kaynaklara baktığınızda,
Don Kişot’un Cami olarak geçiyor.
Peki neden Don Kişot’un Cami demişler?
Çünkü bu camiyi yaptıran Occhiali
isimli bir İtalyan aslında ve devşirme.
Dolayısıyla İnebahtı’nda gösterdiği
kahramanlıktan dolayı
adını Kılıç Ali Paşa yapıyorlar.
Ve Kılıç Ali Paşa, İnebahtı Savaşı
esnasında bir esir getiriyor.
Getirdiği esir ise kim?
Cervantes, yani Don Kişot’un yazarı.
Ve dediklerine göre yıllarca çalışıyor,
hatta kalem işlerinin bazılarını
camideki Cervantes yapıyor.
Bazı kaynaklar daha da ileri gidiyorlar,
diyorlar ki Kılıç Ali Paşa öyle
ilginç bir karakterdi ki,
Cervantes ondan çok etkilendiği için
Don Kişot’un karakterini oturturken
ondan faydalandı.
Ve bu yüzden de batılı kaynaklarda
Don Kişot’un Cami olarak görüyoruz.
Ardından Boğaz’da, bana göre Dünya’nın
en güzel su yolunda ilerlediğimizde,
çok güzel ilginç şeyler karşımıza çıkıyor.
Bir tanesi Beylerbeyi Sarayı.
Beylerbeyi Sarayı’nı biliyorsunuz
Abdüllaziz yaptırıyor.
Önemli sultanlardan biri.
Ve diyorlar ki oraya aslında
Süveyş Kanalı’nın açılışı için
lll. Napolyon’nun karısı geldi.
Yani Eugenie geldi.
Ve Eugenie ile Sultan
büyük bir aşk yaşadılar.
Hatta İspanyol bir yazarın bununla
ilgili bir kitabı da bulunuyor.
Her neyse bu ikili bir gemiye atlıyorlar
ve Süveyş Kanalı’na gidiyorlar.
Şimdi anlatacağım hikâye
Süveyş Kanalı’yla ilgili.
O dönemde Süveyş Kanalı, Mısır,
Osmanlı’nın bir parçası.
Zaten 1914'e kadar da
Osmanlı’ya bağlı kalıyor
ve Hidiv denen valiler
tarafından yönetiliyor.
Sultana diyorlar ki ''Yav sultanım
şu Süveyş Kanalı çok güzel bir yer,
ne de olsa Afrika ile Asya’nın
bir araya geldiği bir nokta.
Neden biz buraya şöyle
görkemli bir eser yapmıyoruz?''
Sultanın da aklına yatıyor,
tamam diyor, parayı da bastırıyor.
Bunlar Fransız Frederic Bartholdi
isimli bir heykeltraş buluyorlar.
Ve Frederic Bartholdi, Gustave Eiffel’in,
yani Eyfel Kulesi’ni yapan
Gustave Eiffel’in yardımıyla iç
mekaniğini hazırlıyor, heykeli bitiriyor.
Tam dikecekler bizimkiler vazgeçiyor.
Diyorlar ki ''Yav biz
müslüman bir ülkeyiz,
eğer biz bunu dikersek
millet bizi topa tutar.
O yüzden de projeden vazgeçiyorlar
ve Frederic Bartholdi
bu güzelim heykeli
maalesef bir depoya kaldırmak
zorunda kalıyor.
Aradan yıllar geçiyor, 1869’da
Süveyş Kanalı açılmış,
kanal için Aida operası
özel olarak besteletmiş.
Ve 1876’a geliyoruz, yani Amerika'nın
100. kuruluş yıl dönümüne.
Fransız iş adamları diyorlar ki ''Yav şu
Amerikalı kardeşlerimize
güzel bir hediye versek ne hoş olur.''
Bunun için de Frederic
Bartholdi'le konuşuyorlar.
Adam uyanık, zaten elinde bir tane
heykel var, heykel depoda duruyor.
Hemen heykelin yüzünü biraz değiştiriyor,
annesini model olarak kullanıyor.
Allıyor pulluyor heykeli ve
heykel parçalar hâlinde,
gemiyle New York limanının
girişine götürülüyor.
Hürriyet Heykeli yada Özgürlük Heykeli,
parasını bizim verdiğimiz,
fakat düdüğünü Fransızların çaldığı
bir heykel olarak karşımıza çıkıyor.
Gerçekten İstanbul birbirinden
ilginç hikâyelerle dolu.
Ben şunu söylüyorum,
''İstanbul iyi yada kötü,
her köşesinde bir sürprizin
olduğu bir şehir.''
Altı tane kitap yazmamın sebebi de zaten
İstanbul’a olan aşkımdan kaynaklanıyor.
Ve "İstanbul hakkında her şey"
kitabımın girişinde şunu yazdım,
"Her şeye rağmen dünyanın
en güzel şehri olan İstanbul’a".
Çünkü bunu çok yürekten
söylüyorum, o ''Her Şey''in içini
istediğiniz gibi doldurabilirsiniz.
Ama gene de İstanbul bana göre
Dünya'nın en güzel şehri.
İsterseniz hikâyelerimize devam edelim.
Şimdi Beylerbeyi Sarayı’na
bir uğramıştık.
Onun devamında
Beylerbeyi Cami bulunuyor.
Beylerbeyi Cami’ni yaptıran kim?
l. Abdülhamit yaptırıyor.
Peki Abdülhamit ile biraz sonra
anlatacağım kadının ilişkisi ne?
İki tane küçük Fransız kızın hikâyesi bu.
Kızlar Paris’te okuyorlar,
fakat Martenik kökenliler.
Martenik biliyorsunuz Karayipler’deki
bir Fransız adası.
Ve kızlar bir falcıya
gidiyorlar çocukken.
Falcı kristal küresini çıkartıyor
bakıyor, diyor ki,
''Vallahi'' diyor ''ikiniz de kraliçe
olacaksınız'' diyor.
''Biriniz doğunun yani orientin,
biriniz batının oksidentin
kraliçesi olacaksınız.''
Kızlar bu işe pek
akıl sır erdiremiyorlar.
Yani nasıl olacak da ikimiz de
birden kraliçe olacağız diye.
Ve bu çerçevede ne yapıyorlar?
Okullarına devam ediyorlar,
yıllar geçiyor.
Kızlardan bir tanesi Josephine,
Napolyon’un karısı oluyor.
Ve o dönemde Napolyon Avrupa’nın
büyük bir kısmına hâkim.
Ve batının kraliçesi oluyor Josephine.
Peki Emma’ya ne oluyor?
Emma okulu bitirmiş, bir gemiye biniyor,
tıngır mıngır Atlantik’i geçecekler
ve Martina’ya gidecekler.
Yolda korsanlar durduruyorlar
gemiyi ve kızı kaçırıyorlar.
Önce Cezayir’e götürüyorlar.
Cezayir Beyi hediye olarak
kızı hareme yolluyor
ve kızın adını değiştiriyorlar.
Otuz altı tane Osmanlı Sultanı var,
bunların otuz dördünün
annesi ise devşirme.
O da onlardan bir tanesi.
Bir isim veriyorlar, Nakşidil,
yani gönüllere nakşedilmiş.
Ve Nakşidil Sultan ll. Mahmut’un
annesi oluyor.
Dolayısıyla aynı zamanda Valide Sultan
ünvanına da sahip olduğu için
doğunun, orientin kraliçesi oluyor.
Hikâyeler İstanbul’da hiç bitmiyor.
O kadar kadim bir şehir ki burası,
sekiz bin yıllık bir tarihe sahip.
Nereyi kazsanız altından
ya bir hikâye çıkıyor
ya da tarihi bir eser çıkıyor.
İsterseniz şimdi Boğaz'da, her sene
altmış bine yakın geminin
geçtiği Boğaz’da Bebek’e
doğru ilerleyelim.
Bebek Parkı'nı biliyorsunuz.
Yan tarafında muhteşem bir saray var.
Art nouveau tarzında yapılmış
olağanüstü bir saray bu
ve burada çok ilginç bir kişi yaşıyor.
Hıdiva Emine Valide Paşa.
Peki kim bu kadın?
Mısır kraliçesi.
Ve son hidivin, son Mısır’ın
Valisi’nin annesi.
Peki diyeceksiniz ki ''yav paşa sadece
erkek unvanı değil midir?
Niye bu kadının paşa unvanı var?''
Kadın, yedi yüz yıllık
Osmanlı İmparatorluğu’nda
paşa unvanı almış yegâne
kişi olarak tarihe geçiyor.
Ve burada çok görkemli bir hayat yaşıyor.
Ama 1923’e geliyoruz ve kadın diyor ki
''Artık Türkiye Cumhuriyeti kuruldu,
bu güzelim sarayı Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti’ne hibe etmek istiyorum.’’
Hemen bunun için bir dilekçe yazıyor
ve dilekçeyi Cağaloğlu'na,
valiliğe gönderiyorlar.
Fakat 1923’le beraber
bütün unvanlar kaldırılmış.
Kadıncağız nasıl imzalıyor?
'Hıdiva Emine Valide Paşa' diye.
Kadına bir cevap geliyor
'Bebek’li Emine Hanım’.
Ve kadın küplere biniyor.
Bu aynı ll. Elizabeth'e
"Oxford'lu Elizabeth" demek gibi.
''Nasıl bana böyle bir şey yaparlar,
bu ne cürettir.'' diyor.
Ve hanedanı Mısır Hanedanı
olduğu için Mısır'a veriyor.
Bugün bunu Mısır Konsolosluğu olarak
görmemizin en büyük sebebi de bu.
Ve şehrimiz gerçekten çok enteresan.
Çok güzel filmlere ev sahipliği yapmış.
Üç tane James Bond filmi
düşünün İstanbul’da çekilmiş.
Bir tanesi "Rusya'dan Sevgilerle",
Sean Connery,
bir tanesi "Dünya Yetmez", Pierce Brosnan,
sonuncusunu da biliyorsunuz
"Skyfall" ve Daniel Craig.
Aynı zamanda kült film var, Topkapı.
Peter Ustinov’un Oscar kazandığı film de,
gene bizim ülkemizde çekilmiş
ve çok enteresan bir özelliğe sahip.
Mission Impossible’ın,
yani Görevimiz Tehlike’nin de
esinlendiği film olarak tarihe geçiyor.
İstanbul’un sürprizleri
gerçekten bitmiyor.
Bu şehirde yaşamak bence
çok büyük bir avantaj,
çok büyük bir, tanrının verdiği
bize bir lütuf.
Onun için de ben kelimelerimi
aynı şekilde bitiriyorum.
İstanbul’da yaşamayın,
İstanbul’u yaşayın.
( Alkış )
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum hepinize.